[Music]
hello everybody welcome thanks for
getting up so early and be here bright
and early for our session my name is
sergeant Wu Guang I'm a product manager
in Google cloud and here with me is
Huang Oviedo also a product manager in
cloud and we have Rakesh Khurana
senior product owner at A&Z here we're
going to tell you all about end-to-end
security and compliance we are
kubernetes deployment in today's talk I
will start by going over a few key
concepts of supply chain security well
how does it work how do used to work for
VMs and how container changes things up
a bit then Rakesh is going to talk about
and while I attended who is in that and
what is in well then we'll introduce a
few tools on GCP that will help you
secure your software supply chain and in
that it's going to go over a few key use
cases they have and a demo of how it
works in action so I'll get it started
first supply chain security 101 when we
talk about supply chain the most common
type of supply chain is food supply
chain co-ops are planted harvested
milled into flowers baked into bread
delivered to our dinner table and then
we ask questions about our food is it
organic where did it come from
is it FDA food very similarly code goes
through a similar type of cycle
developers write code code get chatting
get baked into images go through tests
and verification and go through quality
controls then deploy it to our
production environment having access to
super sensitive security resources and
then we have security holders and
compliance officers asking questions
where does this code come from is it
vulnerability free does it need my
compliance requirement and most
importantly with all the requirement
that I have to meet how do I meet all of
them without losing speed of my
development
so for traditionally for rien based
workloads many customers wrong big
monolithic applications that gets
released only a few times a year due to
its scale and the complexity involved to
release it for each release security and
compliance stakeholders have to manually
inspect every components of the release
to make sure that it's approved and it's
up to date its vulnerability free and
once and because VM is a opaque format
this process is cumbersome to say the
least and eventually when the code is
finally released to production a number
of people need access to the running
applications fairly regularly to apply
ongoing patches ongoing maintenance and
fine-tuning so this is a very manual
process and many different roles in the
organization have direct access to the
running application because we need to
react to problems discovered during
runtime so it's a very reactive security
model as well so it's a process that
we're probably all familiar with but not
necessarily love how does container
change things up the wall is going to
tell us how that works
Thank You Sandra hello everyone so as
we've seen with VMs typically there are
many manual steps that sometimes take a
significant amount of time
this is manageable because of the number
of components involved and the time
between releases those two variables are
very different in the world of
containers microservices multiply the
number of jobs and an oppressed conjoin
can running production and currency icd
systems enable teams to have multiple
deployments a day ensuring that the
proper security checks are performed in
each of these deployments is
very challenging historically the
process of restricting what can be
deployed has relied on human trust an
operational knowledge and that doesn't
really scale to a volume of deployments
that we see with containers so now that
we know about some of these challenges
provided by containers what are some of
the properties that they offer that we
can use to help us apply security while
providing velocity containers have some
unique properties first they are
declarative which means that as you
build them the set of libraries versions
and components are clearly laid out this
also means that because of their
declarative nature they're also
aesthetically in spectable which means
that you can scan them for non securable
and abilities as soon as they're built
without needing to to run the container
image and another key property is that
they are immutable because they are
uniquely identified by a digest that
once created can be altered this enables
you to track a particular container as
it moves through your software supply
chain so given these properties what are
some steps that we can take to apply
security while enabling our teams to
create and move with velocity first we
can build from trusted sources which
means using a set of pre-approved and
regularly patched and maintained base
images these images should also have the
minimal set of dependencies that are
nearby your service and it's something
that should be controlled by have a
common base for your organization also
you should have a streamlined security
checkpoints as part of your release
process this means applying
vulnerability scanning and other
security related tests as your artifacts
move through a supply chain and you
should also define policies that enable
you to apply consistent rules across
different deployments performed by the
different teams in your organization so
as we've seen containers have some
properties that present challenges but
also create opportunities to apply
security while maintaining velocity now
I'm going to hand it over to Rakesh so
he can tell us how a an set is
in this space thank you morning
everybody um so before we talk about
what aliens dare to do it lets sir just
explain who aliens that actually is so
we're at financial services institution
based out of Australia we are
approximately or probably the third
largest bank and within the region based
on market cap about 50,000 employees ten
million ten million customers and we
operate in probably over 30 to 32
countries depends on how you classify
that so I just want to give you a bit of
a view of kind of the size of our
enterprise the scale of kind of what
we're trying to do in how big we are and
we're based out of so if you look at
kind of what and where is there were two
key things that we identified so one was
the technology landscape was changing
and what that opened us up to was a
different competitive landscape excuse
me we found that within Australia
fintechs near banks are really starting
to actually disrupt the market but what
we also found was our customers had a
different expectation so in a digital
world where the technologies actually
evolved and we were able to offer
digital capabilities and digital
services we found that our customers
wanted something very different from us
as a banking institution so we knew we
needed to adapt and what we decided was
we were already building great customer
experiences but we felt that what we
needed to do was build them much faster
and build them at scale and and well or
new ways of working is our way of
basically trying to achieve that so and
where is an organizational
transformation it starts with us
reorganizing ourselves across squads
tribes domain so actually we're going to
redesign and we have been redesign our
organization so you can see their CEO
basically said he wanted to blow up our
bureaucracy and actually get the
organization much more customer centric
and product focused it doesn't stop
there were also streamlining a lot of
our organizational processes and our
governance approaches so what we wanted
to do is strip and streamline as many of
them as possible and to allow our
employees to actually folk
the consumer and embrace a chilly and to
deliver value to the consumer faster um
third and finally and probably most
importantly and technology you still
something we want to tackle and have
been tackling so we know as an
organization that are is over a hundred
eighty years old and as part of this
transformation our technology landscape
had to also evolve and change the shift
and to make advantage of the product
centricity and agility we're trying to
embed with some of our organizational
and process redesign so what are we
actually doing from a technology
perspective we're doing a whole range of
things I'm not going to talk to all of
them there's probably two key things
that I want to highlight so one is we
want to continue our journey with
containerization which we started
several years ago so we felt there and
we still believe our containerization
gives us pace it gives us greater
stability but probably most importantly
it allows us to build good technology
with good practices as part of that
though what we've also identified is
another opportunity so what we started
to identify across the organization and
what you'll see on the left-hand side
the picture is we have very bespoke
release practices some of that related
to the things the guys have already
talked about and but some of that
related to as teams started to embrace
containerization they started to develop
their own release practices and
automation in pockets and silos so what
we wanted to do is actually give the
organization and give our engineers a
way to develop engineer and actually
push code to customers in an
industrialized way utilizing an
industrialized see ICD capability which
we are calling the pave roads or as
we've kind of referred to here already
is our supply chain so um the idea of
this is it doesn't just only help our
engineers but it also helps our
customers get access to our products and
features and value add a lot earlier um
Ian said is a great place to work for a
whole range of reasons and I say that as
an NSAID employee and but one of the key
things for us is that we are continually
evolving in a learning organization so
and we don't like to rest on ideas that
we're starting to develop and push but
we kind of look for opportunities and
that's inbred in our culture in our DNA
so as we started to progress down these
roads
and we started to ask ourselves some
kind of open questions to ourselves and
said what we're doing is good but it's
not great
so what we're doing that opens us up for
speed in pockets but then how do we
scale that so the guys already talked a
little bit about containerization gives
us scaling challenges so we started to
acknowledge what can we do to actually
scale the work we're doing across the
entire breadth of our enterprise and it
also that opens it up to actually
thinking about our operational processes
how can we govern run operate and think
about security better and how do we
actually start to embed that into our
organization and then as we progress
past that we started to think about how
we automate governance so can we
automate a lot of the things that we
would normally do as part of a supply
chain manually can we automate that
using some of these capabilities or
using some of the new technologies
available to us and to make that even
more streamlined and the final bit for
us was I mentioned earlier we operate
across 30 odd countries so the key thing
for us is what that means is we have 30
different regulators that manage
financial institutions across those
countries that we have to answer to we
have to show compliance to we have to
work within the breadth of remit that
they give us within their country and so
we're not just an organization
delivering financial services in
Australia but because we work across 30
organised 30 countries we have 30
regulators to work with and we
continually are asking ourselves is
there a way that we can start to
demonstrate compliance in a different
way but making lives make our lives a
little bit easier so I've talked a
little bit about what a ins that is and
what we're trying to achieve the reasons
for kind of what we're trying to do and
what I'm going to do is hand back over
to Google to see if they can give us
some insights and some products that can
help with that journey one Thank You
Rakesh so let's take a moment to
remember a great product product
experience that you had in the past
remember the excitement you felt as you
were opening that box and turning on the
device or as you were signing up for an
accountant that new service or as you
were being handed the keys to a new car
for you to get to that point you had to
make a decision to trust that
product was going to deliver on its
promise and for you to continue to use
that product and continue to get value
from it you had to continue to to
believe that that Trust was going to be
fulfilled so in essence for customers to
have a great customer experience there
has to be trust that the product will
deliver our own own what it promises and
in order for your customers to to give
your product a try they have to to have
that trust but also for them to have the
potential to eventually become loyal
customers that trust needs to be
maintained and security is key to
maintaining that trust and that's why at
Google cloud we are focused on giving
you solutions that enable you to apply
security while enabling your teams to
create and take advantage of the
velocity provided by containers so
looking at the different stages of the
software supply chain we provide
different solutions starting with cloud
build our CIC platform you can use it to
build different kinds of source code
from different repositories from there
you can make use of the manage base
images that that I will go into more
detail soon then as the different
artifacts are built and the container
images are pushed to container registry
we scan them for known security
vulnerabilities this gives you the
ability to identify those issues early
on and the opportunity to address them
if needed then you can use binary
authorization to define deployment time
policies to ensure that only artifacts
that meet your organization's
requirements can be deployed and then
once your service is running we
continuously analyze the the artifacts
and if there are any new security issues
uncovered a V are known vulnerabilities
who makes information available to you
so now let's go into detail with some of
these products starting with Google
manage base images manage base images
are maintained by us at Google they are
available for Debian Ubuntu and CentOS
and can be downloaded or obtained from
our marketplace they are scanned for
non-secure a boner abilities using GC
our vulnerability scanning and we
regularly patch these images and keep
them up to date we use these images in
on products such as app engine and they
are a great resource that's available to
you to start your development process
from a secure base now let's talk about
container registry vulnerability scanner
container registry vulnerability
scanning checks the images that you push
to to a registry for non-secure a burner
abilities its supports scanning of
images based on ubuntu debian alpine Red
Hat and CentOS a we continuously ingest
data from the corresponding vendor
security feeds and if any new
vulnerabilities are found that apply to
your images we make this information
available to you where the product also
has integration with pops of
notifications which enables you to
automate certain processes for example
you could automatically notify certain
members of your team when a new
vulnerabilities found or you could
automatically file a bug when
vulnerabilities are found now let's talk
about cloud goal for a moment cloud
build is our platform provided CI CDE
solution with cloud build you can build
from different source code repositories
you can build different kinds of
artifacts such as maven packages and
container images as I mentioned earlier
as those the images are built and
they're pushed to GC are they're scan
for known vulnerabilities you can also
set up your corresponding tests as part
of the cloud build process and when they
ask the images and the different
artifacts are deployed to your service
the the whole experience is covered as
part of the platform so it's a great
resource that's available to you and now
let's focus on the plumbing piece and
I'll hand over to Sandra so she can tell
us how by narrator ization can help you
apply security at that stage thank you
so finalisation miner Association is a
deploy time policy enforcement tool
point so what does it mean it integrates
with gke deployment api and examines
every deployment request that comes
through the api to make sure that the
image has proper signature that meets
your customer defined policy before it
can be admitted
into a production environment the policy
is configurable you can define the right
policy that works for your organization
so you know it Amin remaining that
something passes a particular security
scan it means that images are blessed by
QA engineers in meaning that image is
beauty your trusty builder or all three
above the binarization uses standard
signature verification so it can be
plugged into your existing c ICD tools
if you don't choose to use the GCP
provided products it just means that you
have to put a signature on the image
before it gets deployed so the way it
works is by authorization integrates
with your CI CD pipeline and record a
signature as image passes through each
of the stages in your CI CD pipeline and
the signature signifies that the image
has satisfied the requirement for that
particular stage for example the buter
would put image put a signature on your
image saying I'm the secure butor I
build this image or the scanner would
put a signature image basically means
this image has satisfied my scanning
policy requirement and as happens the
image comes to be deployed I deploy time
there are a number of signatures already
available for verification
now banner Association takes a look of
those signatures compared with the
policies that you've designed and says
okay this is a good image satisfy all
the other requirement in addition to
just being deployed by a authorized
person so yes it's a it's a two two
level check the right person is
deploying it and the right content is
being deployed if image does not have
the satisfactory signature on it then
binarization would block it and record a
Auto log for future reviews there are
break glass mechanisms available so if
your developer is trying to push a
change that does not need a policy but
needs to be applied anyway they can
break glass and this would generate a
Autolog as well for your security team
to review this incident later on some of
the popular policies to be applied at
wrong time as I mentioned earlier is our
making sure the image is actually
beautify my organization image make sure
that image has past security checks QA
checks integration checks and so on or
making sure that when I deploy a
third-party image that I did not build
it needs a explicitly set whitelist
that is managed by my security team so
we're releasing GA at this year's google
next so we're very happy that our
products is going to be generally
available there are a few new features
that were pushing out with our GA
release one of those is a dry run
feature dry ROM it means that you're
able to now set a policy in
non-enforcement mode so that you can try
out new deployment policies without
risking production interruption again we
integrate with cloud autolog for any
would be block deployment attempt and so
we were recording Auto log and can
review that later on to make sure that
everything is working fine before you
turn on enforcement for real
and another new feature that is coming
out is system container policies so when
you are running on gke there are a
number of gke of Google own system
containers that are running in your
cluster as part of the orchestration
system things like containers used for
logging or monitoring for example so
even though these system containers are
managed by Google users could deploy a
alternative version of the system
containers to your cluster and it's a if
they attack surface so how do we you
know before customers basically have to
make sure that yes I am deploying the
right versions of the system connection
making sure that those
Penner's are not being over with um with
Vanuatu zation GA we try to automate
that for you we have a default global
policy that we created by working with
the gke release and beauty to make sure
that every system container that is
viewed by Google that build by GE team
it's time and that we're able to verify
that signature for you at deploy time
using this global system container
policy if you opt in so with this on top
of very existing customer define policy
and third-party image whitelisting or
you will have your entire cluster
workload accounted for so in your
cluster all the customer in-house beaut
images will be signed by you have a
signature requirement form your customer
defined policy or the third-party images
will be specified in the image whitelist
that is can be managed by your security
team centrally all the Google own system
containers will be signed by the gke
release team and verified a deployed on
as well last but not least we also have
cloud kms support in beta so now you can
sign your images using Kies managed in a
symmetric key Spanish in the cloud can I
service you don't have to have the
hassle of managing your own keys anymore
if you don't want to and along with this
we also have generic pkcs key support so
if you have keys managed elsewhere in
your preferred PKI
you can use those with binarization
as well so so far I talked about the
hosted you know final authorization
product and other vulnerability scanning
base image products that we host on the
tcp platform but we also want to create
a open platform and that is why we we we
created open source project gracias plus
kritis that are open source reference
implementation implementations of the
container analysis metadata API and
binary authorization that are available
for any kubernetes deployment
anywhere so we work with a number of
industry partners and j-rod Red Hat IBM
black Doug Whitlock and more to create
the standard metadata format so that
they can be plugged in to your existing
CCD pipeline you may not have to use the
Google provided product to get the
benefit of the secure framework we want
to create a knowledge base for you so
it's a metadata API where you can record
findings and facts about it containers
that it's going through your CITV
pipelines that it's going to run or your
security infrastructure in knowledge
base where you can like plugging
meditators signatures vulnerability
findings that you can browse through and
use for enforcement reasons or just for
additional context it plugs into the
communities admissions controller so you
have kubernetes deployment anywhere you
can use kritis and it would enforce
signature based policy of our ability
based policy for you I deployed on as a
mission that we have a number of support
from partners and it's open source view
with community contributions are welcome
check it out if you're interested so
with this we hope to create a open
ecosystem where you can pick and choose
which component you want to which vendor
you want to use for each of the
component you may have a different beaut
process using circle CI or Clos B's and
you may have a different scan process
based on black duck or twist lock and
you may choose to deploy
use spinnaker or you want to deploy it
manually it does not matter we want to
create this general framework where you
can still record the metadata the
signatures and the findings in the
databases that you can centrally access
and manage we still want to give you the
ability to control what goes into a
production environment using the kritis
admissions controller to enforce that
policy centrally as well so here with
open source tools that we've you know
published along with our product we hope
to achieve that
all right so we talked a lot about
technology so how does it work for a
real customer okay you want to show us
thank you so I'm gonna do two or three
things in this next segment so I'm going
to talk to you about what we're actually
doing as a bank I'm going and then talk
to you about why we're doing it and then
show you a small snippet of how we've
put that into practice and what does
that mean for our organization so let's
start with the with the wat now this it
looks like a very busy slide and it's
there deliberately it's there to show
you the complexity of where our
organization sits in terms of engineers
getting code out the door to customers
so what we've been doing is we've been
working with our engineering teams
across the organization to say and what
what would you like what would this
process look like if you wanted an
industrial IC ICD capable e how would it
look and what are the key elements you
require to make that journey to the
customer as seamless and as quick as
possible I'm not going to talk for all
of it but what you're basically seeing
is from left to right it's a typical CI
OCD pipeline we do a bit of code
scanning we're using check marks at the
moment or static code analysis check
marks we're doing CI with Google cloud
cloud build I can see the guys in the
audience were actually using black duct
for code scanning one of the aspects
you're not seeing there is we're doing
vulnerability scanning with twistlock
at this point in time and but for us
it's the ecosystem model where we can
pull and plug tools and actually
integrate them with Google's offering
and as you progress towards the
right-hand side we've chosen a
continuous delivery tool spinnaker to
help us with our deployment capabilities
to do at the moment just do deployments
but maybe move towards some clever items
such as canary deployments or blue
greens or whatever we may end up and
what our engineers want to use and what
our teams need to make their lives
easier and the other bit to call out
here is what you're seeing in terms of
the complexity of those numbers is where
we plan to build these other stations or
ass and record them signatures so the
idea is that as things progress through
these pipeline or this pipeline capable
is what will happen is these are the
stations of these signatures will be
created and then binary authorization
with spinnaker will enforce that they
are available and and present when we
try and deploy a container so as it
contained it progresses through this and
gets to spinnaker for a deployment if it
doesn't see all the other stations in
binary off basically says that this does
not fit with your organizational
policies that we have defined it'll
block the deployment so for us did the
value out here is a range of things but
for us it ensures that the organization
when it's deploying containers into
production and goes to our customers
it's met a set of requirements that we
are comfortable with as a banking
organization so why use this capability
so I've already referred to earlier on
around the engineers experience which is
critical for us as an organization we
want to ensure that the engineers have a
seamless way to get what they're
building into our customers hands I've
already highlighted the speed aspect in
a digital world and with the
transformations and the change in
competitive landscape speed to customer
is key as we build a new feature we want
to get that into our customers hands as
quickly as possible but then we start to
move into the real value add for me kind
of what I've described is you know see
ICD pipelines and stuff we've been doing
as an industry for a while but a
critical value add for me is how we then
use binary authorization to automate our
governance so as engineers utilize these
pipelines as an organization in terms of
our Bret for 50,000 employees we can be
sure that anybody they're pushing
pushing workloads to production meet a
set of organizational policies that we
can and we can enforce change and
redesign on the fly using this
capability which gives us the ability to
do and technology governance as code
essentially but that's not enough for us
so what we then started to think through
is to say well if we're enforcing
technology governance is code and we're
using these capabilities to ensure that
we don't break our appetite from an
organizational perspective around tech
well why couldn't we do that with some
of our other requirements in terms of
our organization
one of our business governance what
about our risk appetite as a bank can we
not start to codify some of those
aspects and start to enforce them via
these sorts of capabilities
now that's just something we're starting
to think through and starting to adapt
so it's it's very much an open question
mark but that's where we're heading
towards this silence and look at as an
organization how do we govern ourselves
how do we manage ourselves in terms of
risk in an automated way and using that
like something like binary or to enforce
that where we do something it doesn't
change our core values or it doesn't
change our core requirements so it
doesn't change and what appetite we have
as an organization and again just to
draw off as we start to progress that
that world how do we then use this to
show compliance across dirty odd
regulators and we want to do that in an
automated way we don't want to be
demonstrating a set of documents or a
set of requirements in a different
format for whether we a Peru or Mars in
Singapore or whoever we want to ensure
that they have the ability and they have
the confidence that they can explore
these capabilities with us and give that
we can give them the confidence that we
can demonstrate compliance differently
so that's the that's still kind of what
we're trying to set out to do and why we
feel that there's a good business case
and good appetite for us to go do this
and we're going to show you a very short
video as we hit play so I want you guys
to bear in mind this is just our MVP it
was kind of what we started off with but
it should give you a feel for how some
of these tools are coming together to
make what I've described and what the
team have described come to life so what
you're what you're going to see in this
first part of the video is basically
cloud build being used to execute some
CI so this is the aspect of where we
could also add complexity by integrating
with Blackduck integrating with check
piles and actually starting to actually
validate that our code that we're
building and our CI capabilities are fit
for purpose what we then will do is as
we've built the artefact will then try
and deploy it so what you're seeing here
is spinnaker attempting to deploy the
artifact we've just created
what you'll see at the bottom there or
just about is that the is the build
failed and what you can see here is as
we highlight oh I think we're just
moving around bear with us I want to
make sure that we'll have the high
quality because it's a really blurry
okay it looks good on this screen so
sorry right you know we can just quickly
remind back a little bit if you haven't
seen so we use spinnaker to attempt a
deployment so the key aspect to see here
is that CD RCD tall is trying to deploy
the artifact we've just created and what
you'll see there at the bottom is that
that's fail and when you look into the
information about why it's buried you'll
see there it actually says that no
matter station was Fairless it would
configure the spinnaker to look for a
particular attestation and so as I
described earlier that can become more
complex this one's just a single
attestation but it can become numerous
um what you saying here is manually
creating an attestation now in a normal
pipeline we want as many other stations
de crédit or in an automated fashion but
we still want to keep the ability that
where we have manual intervention we can
manually create an attestation and
that's where we're going to sit probably
in the short to medium term and we know
this is an evolving journey for us and
then what you'll see is as we progressed
in that other stations we created will
trigger that deployment again using
spinnaker again you'll see in a manual
deployment but we've actually now
automated that and this time what you'll
see is a spinnaker will execute and that
deployment will be successful and the
reason it's been successful is this time
as its try to deploy is actually look
for that attestation it's found that at
a station and actually then basically
said yep it meets the organizational
policy that's been defined previously
and then the video just finishes with
ass basically refresh in the console and
what you'll see this time hopefully
where I know it's hopefully it's a video
so it's been predefined that it's there
it's successful and there it is green
available for consumers to use so and we
wanted to just give you a short video
one because I'm not overly technical so
that me trying to do that on the fly
would have failed miserably but two it's
just an MVP and that we've developed a
while back so what I want you two guys
to take away from this is that
complexity I showed you in terms of our
overarching CICE pipeline the different
types of other stations and this is just
a way to bring all of that to life and
to say this is how we're going to
continue to add complexity as we evolve
that capability out in the bank so I
think it was just a couple of final
comments from me really so it was been
it's been hard and challenging right so
in you're trying to change an
organization from a number of fronts and
you're trying to embed some of these
practices these ideas and it's
challenging for a whole range of reasons
I think if anybody here has done
transformation programs you're attest to
how difficult trying to push some of
this change through is we we have I
basically said it's definitely worth the
investment in the effort so it's been
hard work and it's it's been a bit of a
slog however we're already seeing the
benefits of the work we're doing and
we're not even fully all the way through
our journey we're got you know probably
two or three iterations of our pipeline
we've got more to do we want to start to
tackle the organizational stuff and
we've already started to see the
benefits and the the business case for
how we continue and accelerate the work
we're doing so the first bit for us was
is just stick for that initial challenge
raise and two we interestingly enough
what we found was as we started to
embrace some of this and put some of
this into practice it actually started
to inform us of how we needed to evolve
some of our technology landscape and
wider fields whether it be on-premise or
some of our thinking or some of our
overarching processes and we've managed
to shift left some of that work so we've
managed to actually identified things
that could have been a problem two or
three years down the line by actually
embracing this world and actually
getting on with this aspect that then
informs the other things that we need to
change and thirdly it's often said with
a change program bring people on the
journey and it's usually said because
you know it's the change process and you
get P
but what we've found is actually the
reason to bring people on the journey
early is that they started to get
involved in this and they actually
really loved it and enjoyed it and
actually started to wanting to be part
of it so we've started to see a real
cultural shift and a real coalition
around the organization of people
wanting to adopt the work we've been
describing so not only spread the
message and bring people on journey to
help them embrace the change but
actually what we've found is we've just
found helping hands across the
organization to make this a reality for
us so I think we're into closing remarks
so the only only bit for me to close
with is hopefully what you've seen is a
and Ed's approach to kind of how we want
to change and some of the things we do
I've described a little bit of the why
we need to do that and hopefully I've
brought together kind of how we're using
some of the Google Google's capabilities
to bring that to life and we have two
main outcomes one is to make ends at an
amazing place to work for engineers but
two as quickly as possible get consumer
value out the door and get it into our
hands of our customers and we see the
the work I've described there's a
critical aspect to achieve both those
goals as we move forward so I'll hand
back to Google Thank You Rakesh so as
we've seen the appliance security in the
coronary supply chain has some
challenges but also creates great
opportunities to both apply that
security enable your teams to create and
to make a take advantage of that
velocity and as a result to provide your
customers with great experiences and
maintain their trust so here's a summary
of some of the products that we talked
about today they are available as sundar
mentioned a vulnerability scanning and
binarization are going GA Suen managed
based images are available for you to
use right now so these are some great
resources that we make available to you
and we look forward to how you use them
and and give us feedback and here are
some related presentations on the topic
of security and containers you can find
a videos for these compressing tations
on youtube now or in the near future
[Music]